I am really so incredibly happy
there are
just accepted 5 subscriptions and 8 emotions from us
I am going to list them for you very soon
and directly
end to the gas finger from groningenveld in law
evidence presumption for the whole of the Netherlands and all mining
stop talking and negotiate with gel
and 1 hard legal line
never cut back on money pledged to skinned
Forcing Xiao and exon to pay
no new inequality
create through the end of gas extraction
duty of care also for Groningen in law
and 1 aftercare plan in law
no limitation period for damage after 30 years
see deep subsidence as a cause of damage
and the vibration beam
no longer use
no new inequality because of the cabinet
is demisionary
offering mediation to the garupt
SAY a joke about sustainability
with this of course the misery is far from over
but these are very nice steps and that gives hope
and we continue for much more